vous avez bien lu louhans lieu de
personnes qui font le ramadan dans mon
entourage est très majoritairement je
suis honnête avec vous il ya huit
personnes sur dix qui m'ont dit que ça
ne valait pas le coup d'en faire une
polémique parce que ça devait être il
fallait que ce soit une erreur mais ces
personnes là me disais aussi j'espère
que c'est une erreur j'espère que tu
encore les têtes une étude sur l'amour
des femmes alors que non toutes les pubs
toutes les pubs pour la bouffe et les
boissons pendant le ramadan d'être
interdite alors est ce que vous dit oui
à arrêter mais s'il avait déjà bu à la
mélodie de parler son mécha s'il vous
plaît j'aime les gens me sied à 3h16
pour moi c'est une provocation midi
gigean meciar et savoir mais bousquet
joueurs c'est que le ramadan existants
mais c'est ce que vous avez fait vous
devriez utiliser
je sais c'est pas votre mieux répartie
cela je viens je viens d'un pays
musulman où j'ai vu le ramadan depuis
tout petit vous l'avez découvert trois
auriez vous excuser du tweet et de
d'avoir lancé contre moi a lancé cette
année les gens d'extrême droite qui ont
fait d'aimer notre propre étude à nager
par propres il je me sens très des crs
et des châssis nous sommes très touchés
par est passé lui pourquoi est ce que
c'est ce qui serait touché parce que en
fait on peut tout me dire moi je suis et
sincère je dirais savagnier mesures
franchement tout auto mais là il ya eu
une organisation lancée par jean
messieurs arrêtez vision complotiste les
la 2e et la deux personnes qui le
suivent les pas de panique et
désagréable
lanciné gon qui a lancé les gens contre
vous c'est votre propre idiotie les
c'est une il y en a un peu plus et ces
gens là sont actifs et mais il ya eu un
déferlement de l'extrême droite avec des
menaces précises sur moi sur mon
entourage
donnez nous des exemples c'est tu ne
viendra pas quand tu vas te faire
agresser un jour voilà mesdames vous
faut plusieurs dizaines de menaces
ciblées porter plainte
plusieurs centaines j'hésitais gens mais
sia/gsea téléphone et lui et laurier et
lui c'est l'arrêt s'est haussé la voix
de son acte mais si vous savez sur les
visites étaient des plaintes ya une loi
depuis 2000 je vais voter contre les
raids numérique et le cyber vous pouvez
allez vous rendre quelque part dans un
commissariat ou une gendarmerie porter
plein vous pouvez aussi je le dis pour
ceux qui nous regardent aller sur une
plateforme qui s'appelle arrêtons les
violences point gouv.fr préparer la
plainte de choses syrie si vous me
permettez
est-ce qu'on pourrait peut-être se dire
que collectivement le cyber harcèlement
et les menaces de mort ne sont pas des
moyens d'avancer dans le débat quelle
que soit la période sur où l'entreprise
vers lesquelles elles sont dirigées et
le débat elle écoute sont peut-être plus
efficace et ensuite peut-être se dire
qu'il ya une immense majorité des
personnes qui n'ont pas envie d'être
prises entre une forme de paranoïa ou
une forme de haine d'extrême droite et
qui simplement souhaite que chacun se
respecte dans sa liberté de croire ou de
ne pas croire sans être inquiété pour
l'ajustement c'est l'article 278